[Music]
to start with this topic we have to
discuss first the nine realms which are
all located within the igrassel tree a
cosmic connection that spans millions of
galaxies and we have come to that
conclusion by watching the credit scenes
of the first thor movie and it seems
that the egg russell tree is in fact a
galactic supercluster which looks very
similar to the branches of a tree when
viewed from afar so here in this
galactic supercluster known in the mcu
as igrassel and in real life as maybe
the lanayakea we have the milky way
galaxy and a multitude of others the egg
wrestle connects them all with nine
distant planets in nine distant points
of space time constituting the nine
realms
firstly we have asgard home of the
asgardian gods that is on the head of
the egg wrestle tree away from any
galaxy present in intergalactic space it
is a planetoid body that is spiral in
shape with a center holding the city of
asgard
second we have earth home to humans and
in humans it is located in the milky way
galaxy which is present in the center of
the egg russell supercluster
then we have vanaheim home to the sister
race of the asgardians known as the
veneer it is located in a yet unknown
galaxy but it is closer to the head of
the egg drastic tree close to asgard
then we have alpheim home to the light
elves and freyja it is further away from
asgard in the left end of the egg
wrestled galactic supercluster seen once
in the convergence during thor the dark
world
then we see svartalheim a dark world
orbiting a black hole close to
intergalactic space and corroded with
dark matter this is home to the dark
elves and they evolved here under a
diverse a more diverse table of elements
then we come to the nida valley home to
the dwarves and the forge of the
asgardian weaponry it is in an alderson
disk that orbits a neutron star present
in a yet unknown galaxy in the bottom
left of the egg drastic supercluster
then we come to nilfheim also known as
the location for hell present in the
opposite end of asgard in the egg
drastic cluster tree it is here that
odin imprisons heller in a world of
darkness and lifelessness
then we come to jotunheim home to the
frost giants and a casket of ancient
winters it is present in an unknown
galaxy in the right end of the egg
drastic supercluster
this world is a frozen planet
then the last planet in the nine realms
is maspelheim home to sirte and his fire
demons it is present in a yet unknown
galaxy in the bottom right of the egg
drastic galactic supercluster this
planet is a hellish volcanic world
so now we come to the planets with
coordinates and we found out from the
three or four initial numbers or
alphabets in the coordinates that they
match up with astronomical names for
distant galaxies or star clusters as
well as constellations and other cosmic
objects
for example we checked out the
officially stated location for planet
carbon and it was said to be located in
the andromeda galaxy it also has the
coordinates m31vj0443799
plus four one two nine two three six
well the first four alpha numerals are
m31v which coincides with the object
messier 31 which in real life is known
as the andromeda galaxy so there we have
it
first we have nowhere now a mining
colony but it was once the head of
celestial it is located in the milky way
galaxy delta quadrant with coordinates m
three rd one seven h one seven two one
one plus two one two one two two four
which is in the messier 3 object a
globalist star cluster 32 600 light
years away from earth
next we come to berhad a planet where
the guardians of the galaxy landed after
being chased by the sovereign and it is
in the milky way galaxy with coordinates
m20 22a 483 4i26 plus 306 ca i2 in the
messier 20 system which is a star
forming nebula around 9 000 light years
away from earth next we have chronicle 2
homeworld of the chronic arms an
advanced race of intelligent beings that
are artificial or synthetic
it revolves around a star in the
sickness constellation 72 to 1800 light
years away from earth in the milky way
galaxy
next we have contraxia a cold and icy
planet that the ravages regroup and
rests it has the coordinates m15 512
75127 31 plus x1955kx
which is in the messier 15 system which
is a global star cluster 33 600 light
years away from earth
now we come to maverick located in the
milky way galaxy a few light years away
from earth and thousands of years ago it
was home to an advanced utopian
civilization that was destroyed by the
inhuman hive that was exiled from earth
then we come to hala this is the cree
home world having the coordinates
8k 1m double y 67847
plus
58e698l which is yet undeciphered but
historically it has always been in the
large magellanic cloud approximately a
hundred and sixty thousand light years
away from earth
then after decree we have the skrulls
from torfa it is not the home world the
skrulls but a planet where they inhabit
a stronghold for them it is located in
the border space of the cree empire with
coordinates p137
t55412as 60876
between the milky way and the large
magellanic cloud
then let's travel far away to zander the
home world of the zanderians and also to
many other species as it is the capital
of the nova empire with a population of
12 billion having the coordinates m31v
j004236
plus one two seven zero eight two which
means that it is in the andromeda galaxy
also known as messier 31v
then we have crylor arago7 and ascoveria
which are all part of the nova empire
based on zander
which means they are also in the
andromeda galaxy
next we have corbin well in 2014 corbin
was attacked by thanos and his black
order and his army who slaughtered half
of the planet's population it is in the
andromeda galaxy at an eclipsing star a
binary star system with coordinates m31v
j0443799
plus four one two nine two three six
then next we have morag this planet is
where stala discovered the orb which
houses the power stone it is in the
andromeda galaxy in the same star system
the same binary star system as carbon
with the same coordinates m31vjw437
plus four one two nine two three six
then let's travel further away to the
sovereign it is a collection of a lot of
planets having the coordinates m495i0l
339 p21 plus h9 ln
l31 which is in the messier 49 galaxy
that is 56 million light years away home
to asia and the sovereign people
then we come to vomit this is a remote
barren planet at the very center of
celestial existence within the universe
where the soul stone was located it is a
strange planet that orbits a black hole
just like svatlheim
then we have titan
location yet unknown but most probably
in the milky way galaxy back home given
the fact that captain marvel saved iron
man in deep space and took him to earth
then we come to ego the living planet
who awaken in deep space and located in
a galaxy having coordinates
g522 c848t12
f plus e16uc22
it would be millions of light years away
since rocket raccoon used the universal
neural teleportation network and had to
make 700 jumps to get there
then next we have planet 0259-s
distant unknown galaxy also known as
garden the resting place of thanos this
planet has a lush ecosystem and a
vibrant atmosphere it is a binary planet
with a set of rings around it
and lastly we come to sakhar this is a
battle world planet that is owned by one
of the oldest beings in the universe the
grand master this is an artificial
planet created by the grand master in
the taiyo star system and is surrounded
by numerous wormholes that deposit space
waste
so i hope you have enjoyed watching this
video and anyway with that we come to
the end of it so do hit that like button
for support and subscribe as well to be
a part of the minecube family